he always promised he would be back
Terminator star Arnold Schwarzenegger
and original Sarah Connor actor than the
Hamilton are back in action in a batch
of new photos from the upcoming sci-fi
sequel Terminator dark fate one new
photo released by the studio shows a
grizzled and bearded Schwarzenegger as
the t800 model Terminator sporting a
scar and giving the stink eye to someone
off camera
another depicts Hamilton in character as
Sarah Connor looking older but no less
battle-hardened with a heavy vest of
armor on a chest and aviator sunglasses
vote Terminator dark fate does feature
the two iconic franchise stars it also
brings several new faces into the fold
Mackenzie Davis as a soldier assassin
named Grace Natalya Reyes as Dani Ramos
Diego Boneta as Miguel Ramos and Gabriel
Luna as a new type of terminator IGN
shared stills of each star new to the
series in action with shots including
Davis's grace character staring down an
opponent mid-fight Reyes as Dani peeking
over her shoulder near a parked car in
the middle of an open field Panetta's
Miguel affecting a scowl from behind the
wheel of a truck and the lunes
Terminator dressed in what looks to be a
military uniform or stalking through
some sorts of high-tech facility sets
after the events of t2 Judgment Day dark
fate will effectively do the Terminator
franchise or 2018 Halloween revival did
with his own series by pretending most
of the sequels in the series didn't
happen instead the dark fate is
reportedly picking up at the last point
basically everyone agrees the series was
still good as a result the movie won't
address the events of 2003 Semin a 2/3
rise of the machines 2009 Terminator
Salvation all 2015's much maligned
Terminator Genisys likely for the better
as producer David Ellison once said of
the film's focus I will say we have
resolved a future of the franchise and
believe me as an incredibly bright
future I think where it's going will be
the continuation of what the fans really
wanted since t2 it's something we're
incredibly excited about and we think as
a direction it needs to head James
Cameron the director and writer of the
first two films and the longtime series
producer is also back in the creative
mix for dark fates and he's previously
shared his vision for this
transformative SIF movie and the
franchise speaking in an interview in
July 27th
Kameron express that the goal with the
forthcoming movie is to pass a narrative
baton through the introduction of new
characters while also modernizing the
Domesday narrative to reflect current
technological anxieties he's also a word
that the franchise needs a careful
approach to bring it back in line with
speculative sci-fi ambitions of the
first two movies as Cameron phrased
their the question is has the franchise
run its course or can it be freshened up
can it still have relevance now where so
much of our world is catching up to what
was science fiction in the first two
films despite how important the new
characters may be for evolving and
continuing the Terminator series dark
fate director Tim Miller says that Linda
Hamilton is the most vital piece of this
movie's puzzle he explained to IGN that
Hamilton returning to her role as Sarah
Connor
made a vision for the new sequel fall
into place for him and that's her
presence helps bridge the gap between
past franchise entries and installments
that he had to come the director said
the fact that Linda came back and makes
this particular Terminator fresh this
story could only continue with her in
the role of Sarah Connor that's the most
important thing for me Linda we invented
this character in a way that both honors
who she was before and brings something
new to the role he also gave major kudos
to the new cast all of whom he says hold
their own and bring something new to the
table while sharing the screen with
Hamilton and Schwarzenegger Miller also
teased the movie's focus on character
over big-budget spectacle investing
audiences in the cast before putting
them all in peril he said we have a lot
of powerful moving character moments
upfront but towards the back half of the
movie when gets going it just doesn't
stop and we tried very hard to make it
all different than fresh it's not just
people punching each other it's a
rollercoaster ride and I think it's
great fans can watch his old school
meets new school when Terminator dark
fades arrives in theaters on November
1st check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]